>> ARE YOU LOOKING FOR SOMETHING
TO SPICE UP YOUR LIFE?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> YOU USED TO WANT SEX BUT
YOU'RE IN YOUR LATE 30s NOW.
AND SEX ISN'T REALLY DOING IT
FOR ME ANYMORE.
>> YOU NEED SOMETHING NEW.
>> SOMETHING EXCITING.
>> I NEED A NEW FANTASY, THEN
YOU NEED --
>> YOU NEED --
>> ZILLOW.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> YOU CAN HAVE SEX NOW AND
WE'RE STANDING BY WAITING FOR
YOU.
>> AN UPDATED COLONIAL WITH
MATURE LANDSCAPING.
>> UNLEASH YOUR PASSIONS.
>> I WANT TO FLIP THAT.
>> FIND YOUR FANTASY.
>> I'D NEVER LIVE IN
NORTH CAROLINA, BUT IF I DID I
COULD BUY A BIG, GROSS MANSION.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ZILLOW.
>> SO WHAT ARE YOU WAITING FOR?
PICK UP YOUR PHONE NOW.
OPEN THE APP, AND TELL US WHAT
YOU REALLY WANT.
>> BROWSE BY YOURSELF.
OR GO WILD AND INVITE YOUR
PARTNER.
>> THE GUEST HAS ITS OWN LITTLE
KITCHEN.
OH --
>> SO BAD!
>> THE PLEASURE YOU ONCE GOT
FROM SEX, NOW COMES FROM LOOKING
AT OTHER PEOPLE'S HOUSES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> DON'T WORRY.
YOU GET TOO CARRIED AWAY WITH
THE FANTASY, JUST CLICK CONTACT
LISTING AGENT FOR A RUDE
AWAKENING.
>> WELL, HELLO.
>> HI.
THIS IS DONNA LASEREENY WITH
RE/MAX.
>> OH, HI.
>> YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
13 CLOVER LANE?
>> NO, IM NOT.
>> SO, WHEN ARE YOU FREE?
I CAN'T DO SUNDAY.
>> NO.
NEVER MIND.
I'M NOT ACTUALLY LOOKING TO BUY.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
>> IF YOU'RE IN YOUR LATE 30s.
>> TIME FOR A NEW FANTASY --
>> ON ZILLOW.
>> HELLO?
>> HI, DONNA LAZEREENY AGAIN,
I'M GOING --
>> YEAH, NO.
MA'AM --
>> BUT I HAVE ANOTHER PLACE ON
>> I DON'T WANT TO BUY.